[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen zu 20
Minuten Nachrichten und mit dabei
natürlich auch der Sport heute von
Norbert König genau
als erstes schauen wir auf ein
verheerendes Zugunglück
Griechenland trauert zwei Züge stoßen
frontal zusammen mindestens 36 Menschen
sterben dutzende leiden Verletzungen
Richtungsentscheidung der Berliner SPD
Parteichefin Giffey will
Koalitionsverhandlungen mit dem
Wahlsieger CDU doch es gibt internen
Widerstand
und Silber in der Nordischen Kombination
bei der WM im Planitzer muss sich das
deutsche Männerteam nur den Norwegern
geschlagen geben
ein Albtraum so beschreibt ein Passagier
den Zusammenstoß der beiden Züge in
Griechenland bei dem mindestens 36
Menschen ums Leben kamen und mindestens
85 Menschen verletzt wurden im Land
herrscht eine dreitägige Staatstrauer
weltweit ist die Anteilnahme groß
Bedenken an die Opfer und deren
Angehörige schrieb Kanzler Scholz
es ist das schwerste Zugunglück in der
Geschichte des Landes denn der City mit
rund 350 Personen an Bord war unterwegs
von Athen in Richtung der Hafenmetropole
Thessaloniki nah der Stadt Larissa
krachte er frontal in einen
entgegenkommenden Güterzug obwohl die
Strecke zweispurig ausgebaut ist und
restposte berichtet
der Unglücksort gleicht einem
Trümmerfeld den ganzen Tag über suchen
Rettungskräfte nach Vermissten und
Bergen weitere Tote wie das sogar das
ist die Passagiere waren in einem
Schockzustand sie haben nach Ihren
Mitreisenden gesucht manche hatten
Verletzungen von Glasscherben und vom
Aufprall viele haben erzählt dass sie
geschlafen haben es gab einen Knall und
dann war Dunkelheit
kurz vor Mitternacht war der InterCity
auf freier Strecke mit einem Güterzug
frontal aufeinander geprallt die
vorderen Waggons wurden von der Wucht
komplett zertrümmert fingen Feuer
wir hörten einen großen Knall es folgten
albtraumhaftes Szenen wir drehten uns
mit dem Waggon vielen auf die Seite dann
gab es Panik
wie konnten die Züge auf demselben Gleis
zusammenstoßen obwohl die Strecke
zwischen Athen und Thessaloniki
zweispurig ausgebaut ist trotz
Modernisierung mit neuen Brücken und
Tunneln soll es schon länger erhebliche
Probleme beim elektronischen Leitsystem
gegeben haben im Rundfunk wiederholt der
Vorsitzende der Lokführergewerkschaft
die Kritik an der Rückständigkeit der
griechischen Bahn man fahre wie in alten
Zeiten von einem Streckenteil zum
anderen per Funk ein Stationsvorsteher
wurde bereits verhaftet
Griechenlands Premierminister mit zur
Takis besucht am frühen Mittag die
Unfallstelle und verspricht umfassende
Aufklärung
wir werden die Ursachen dieser Tragödie
herausfinden und alles in unserer Macht
stehende tun damit sich so etwas nie
wieder ereignet
Griechenland Verkehrsminister hat
bereits persönlich Konsequenzen gezogen
und seinen Rücktritt erklärt er
übernehme die politische Verantwortung
für das Schlimmste Eisenbahn Unglück in
der Geschichte des Landes
wir blicken nach Deutschland nach Berlin
da hat die noch Regierende
Bürgermeisterin und
SPD-Landesvorsitzende Franziska Giffey
für Überraschung gesorgt weil sie für
Koalitionsverhandlungen mit der CDU ist
die SPD wäre in der juniorolle es würde
auch für eine Fortführung von rot grün
rot reichen und für Schwarz-Grün zur
Stunde berät der SPD-Landesvorstand mehr
von Markus groß
Weichenstellung bei der Berliner SPD
Franziska Giffey drängt ihre Partei in
Richtung CDU
der Preis dafür hoch als Juniorpartner
würde sie den Chefsessel im Roten
Rathaus verlieren die Meinungen
kontrovers die präpariere war eigentlich
immer Rot-Rot-Grün aber das Bild was wir
abgegeben haben seit 2016 ist blamabel
ist schrecklich und es nicht gut für
eine Stadt Berlin und wenn die
Ergebnisse der Verhandlung so sind wie
sie gehört habe dass eben dieses
streiten weitergeht dann können wir
dieses eingehen der linke Flügel der SPD
zeigt sich enttäuscht vom kursschwenk
also ich habe meine Zweifel dass die CDU
bei der Verkehrswende wirklich sozusagen
voran geht beim Thema Migration
Integration gerade nach den Silvester
Krawallen gab es ja schon
unterschiedliche Herangehensweisen und
da habe ich einfach nur Fragestellungen
wie man da zusammen kommen kann zwei
einhalb Wochen soll die Jungs Gespräche
die Grünen die das bisherige Bündnis
eigentlich fortsetzen wollen fühlen sich
von der SPD Entscheidung überrumpelt wir
finden es sehr sehr schade dass die SPD
jetzt mit so einem Knall über die Medien
uns gegenüber die Tür zugeschlagen hat
weil wir glauben Berlin hätte eine
progressive Regierung verdient und hätte
könnte das auch brauchen und die CDU ist
in Wartestellung hat auch mit den Grünen
ein mögliches Bündnis ausgelotet
Spitzenkandidat Wegener pokert schwarz
grün oder schwarz rot entschieden sein
auch nichts
wir werden morgen unsere Gremien unseren
Landesvorstand befassen dort wird es
auch eine Empfehlung der
sondierungskommission geben denn es geht
um viel es geht um einen politischen
Wechsel für Berlin kommt die SPD-Spitze
mit ihren groko Ambitionen durch heftige
Diskussionen zur Stunde in der
Parteizentrale
und vor der Berliner spd-parteizentrale
steht für uns Silvia blessmann Silvia
also wie wahrscheinlich ist es das CDU
und spd-koalitionsverhandlung aufnehmen
werden
nun wer glaubte Franziska Giffey werde
bis zuletzt an der machtklemmen der
irrte offenbar und das ist wohl das
wichtigste Signal für eine mögliche
große Koalition in der Hauptstadt es ist
ja einfach so dass sie ihr Amt zur
Verfügung stellen will damit ihre SPD
weiter mitregieren kann der eigentliche
Wahl Verlierer hier dieser Wahl und es
ist so dass die rot-grün rote Koalition
ja niemals ihre wirkliche
wunschkoalition war das war hier kein
prima Klima Club der geräuschlos regiert
hat in den letzten anderthalb Jahren und
der Wahl Sieger die CDU die zeigte sich
offenbar sehr handzahm in den
Sondierungsgesprächen und es gab heute
auch eindeutige Signale bereits am
Nachmittag das auch die CDU bereit wäre
mit der
spd-koalitionsverhandlungen aufzunehmen
aber ganz genau werden wir das erst
morgen nachmittag wissen da wird kein
Wegner der Weißiger verkünden mit wem
die CDU dann die Koalitionsgespräche
aufnehmen will vielen Dank
für Millionen Strom und Gaskunden in
Deutschland werden die Rechnung
günstiger ab heute greifen die
energiepreisbremsen rückwirkend auch für
Januar und Februar damit will die
Bundesregierung den Preisanstieg nach
Ausbruch des Ukraine Krieges abfedern
wie die preisbremsen funktionieren und
welche Türken es dabei gibt erklärt
Dominik Müller
sie soll ein wenig Druck aus dem Kessel
nehmen die energiepreisbremse ohne dass
man selbst als Kunde etwas tun muss ab
heute deckelt die Preisbremse bei
privaten Haushalten und bei kleinen
Unternehmen den Preis für 80% des
vorjahresverbrauchs Strom kostet maximal
40 Gas maximal 12 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde ab nun zahlt der Staat
die Differenz zum Marktpreis und auch
rückwirkend für Januar und Februar
eigentlich sollten die Energieversorger
ihre Kunden mittlerweile umfassend
informiert haben aber
die Energieversorger haben schon
angekündigt dass sie vermutlich nicht
alle Informationspflichten werden
nachkommen können auch das schauen wir
uns sehr genau an weil die Kunden und
Kundinnen müssen ja verstehen was
passiert und was abgerechnet wird auch
da sehen wir durchaus Hinweise dass der
Information nicht gut nachgekommen wird
und dass da tatsächlich auch im Zweifel
auch falsche schreiben rausgeschickt
werden selbst überprüfen und nachrechnen
welchen Abschlag man ab nun zu zahlen
hat raten Verbraucherschützer den Kunden
die Preisbremse bringe etwas so der
Tenor außerdem sinkt der Marktpreis seit
Wochen und damit in der Folge auch die
Preise für verbrauche an uns ist es wenn
es ein preiswert und Anbieter gibt dahin
zu gehen weil ich spare bei mir Geld und
anschließend spart auch noch der
Steuerzahler also wir alle Geld weil der
Staat das dann nicht subventionieren
muss weil die neuen Einstiegspreise
teilweise sogar unter den 12 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde liegen die man sowieso
aus eigener Tasche zahlt vergleichen
lohnt sich also wieder
die Inflation in Deutschland bleibt hoch
im Februar sind die Verbraucherpreise im
Jahresvergleich nach einer ersten
Schätzung um 8,7% gestiegen genauso viel
wie im Januar Lebensmittel lösten
Energie als Preistreiber Nummer eins ab
sie verteuerten sich um 21,8 Energie um
19,1%
der deutsche Arbeitsmarkt bleibt in der
Krise relativ stabil laut Bundesagentur
verarbeitet waren im Februar zwei
Millionen 620.000 Menschen ohne Job das
sind 4000 mehr als im Januar im
Vergleich zum Vorjahr sind
192.000 Menschen mehr arbeitslos die
Arbeitslosenquote bleibt unverändert bei
5,7 Prozent
die corona-auflagen sind heute weiter
gelockert BewohnerInnen und Beschäftigte
von Pflegeheimen und Kliniken müssen
keine Maske mehr tragen und sich nicht
mehr testen nur wer zu Besuch kommt muss
Maske tragen das gilt auch in Arztpraxen
die Bundesregierung begründet die
Lockerung mit der weitgehend stabilen
infektionslage
kommen wir zur Außen- und
Entwicklungspolitik da sollen künftig
Mädchen und Frauen gezielter gestärkt
und einbezogen werden das Ziel
Gleichberechtigung das ganze läuft unter
dem Begriff feministische Außenpolitik
was sich Außenministerin bärburg und
entwicklungsministerin Schulze darunter
vorstellen haben sie heute in Berlin
vorgestellt Patricia Wiedemeier beginnt
mit einem Beispiel
in Madagaskar einem der ärmsten Länder
der Welt leisten Frauen ein Hauptteil
der Arbeit auf den Feldern dürfen aber
kaum mitbestimmen dank des Projektes
waratsch vom Hilfswerk Misereor dürfen
sie nun Land erwerben lernen die man
richtig wirtschaftet und erhalten mehr
Rechte die feministische Außenpolitik
komme da gerade richtig eine willkommene
Unterstützung und gerade hier ist es
besonders wichtig dass auf
Regierungsebene verhandelt wird das auf
Regierungsebene die Rechte von Frauen
eingefordert werden was uns dann wieder
in unserer Projektarbeit die wir in den
jeweiligen Ländern ja durchführen bzw
unterstützen auch sehr hilft das
Kabinett hat am Morgen die Leitlinien
verabschiedet Rechte von Frauen
Ressourcen für Frauen Frauenförderung
das sind die Schlagzeilen sie rufe keine
Revolution aus aber da die Hälfte der
Menschheit aus Frauen bestehe müsse
diese Hälfte auch mehr berücksichtigt
werden so bärbock und feministische
Außenpolitik zieht sich durch alle
Bereiche unseres außenpolitischen
Handelns von der humanitären Hilfe über
Stabilisierungsmaßnahmen
Friedensmissionen und auch um der
auswärtigen Kultur und Bildungspolitik
Gesellschaften in denen Gleichstellung
verwirklicht werde sein friedlicher
gerechter nachhaltiger und
wirtschaftlich erfolgreicher auch die
Entwicklungshilfe soll künftig
feministisch ausgerichtet werden wir
wollen mithelfen mit unserer
Entwicklungspolitik den Hunger in der
Welt zu bekämpfen Armut zu bekämpfen wir
wollen Gesellschaften gerechter machen
und da kann man nicht auf die Hälfte des
Potenzials nämlich auf die Frauen
verzichten
feministische Außenpolitik das heißt
auch dass künftig 85% des etas an diese
Vorgaben geknüpft werden
von Berlin aus fliegt Annalena baerbock
in die indische Hauptstadt dort treffen
sich die Außenministerin und Minister
der G20-Staaten dabei wird es auch um
den Ukraine Krieg gehen Indien sieht
sich da als neutral die Importe aus
Russland haben sich von 2021 bis 2022
für fünffacht auf fast 33 Milliarden
Euro vor allem geht es um Öl wie das
trotz der Sanktion über Indien nach
Deutschland kommt zeigt Ihnen
der russellavroff kommt als einer der
ersten seine Schlüsselrolle liegt auf
der Hand lässt sich Russland zu
irgendetwas bewegen ausgerechnet hier in
Indien das von guten Beziehungen zu
Moskau profitiert von Sanktionen will
Delhi nichts wissen im Gegenteil das
Energiegeschäft brummt mehr denn je
Indien ist gerade sehr aktiv dabei
russisches rohlöl zu importieren und
zwar zu sehr günstigen Preisen und das
dann in den heimischen Raffinerien zu
Diesel zu verarbeiten und das dann auch
nach Europa und nach Deutschland zu
verkaufen wir kriegen also so gesehen
weiterhin russisches Öl nur eben jetzt
verpackt in indischen Diesel
so wird dann auch klar warum kaum Kritik
an indiensgeschäft mit Russland laut
wird aber wie wirksam sind Sanktionen
die man verhängt und selbst umgeht warum
macht Deutschland damit kommt erst das
Tanken dann die Moral wir haben dadurch
einerseits die Versorgung an deutschen
Tankstellen gesichert andererseits und
das ist das die gute Nachricht haben wir
schon dafür gesorgt dass Wladimir Putin
deutlich weniger Öl Einnahmen hat im
russischen Staatshaushalt mit dem man
den Krieg finanziert im Geflecht dieser
Interessen sollen die geht 20 Staaten
einen Weg finden die möglichst viele
mitgehen davor wurde heute so gleich
beim indischen Kollegen vorstellig der
Russe ist für seinen festen Händedruck
bekannt für den Gastgeber dürfte
spätestens damit klar sein dass was auf
ihn zukommt Vermittlung in der
Weltpolitik scheint gerade komplizierter
denn je
alle Augen also auf Indien warum das
Land so umarnt wird sowohl vom Westen
als auch von Russland das können Sie
nachlesen in unserer ZDF heute App
in Israel reist der Prozess gegen die
geplante Justizreform der ultra-rechten
Regierung von Benjamin italiao nicht ab
von neuen Beratungen im Parlament gab es
Aktionen im ganzen Land bei Tel Aviv
blockierten am Morgen demonstrierende
die hauptautobahn nach Jerusalem dabei
kam es zu Zusammenstößen mit der Polizei
durch die Reform wird die
Gewaltenteilung in Gefahr gesehen und
gewarnt dass Israel sich in eine
Diktatur verwandeln könnte
in Nigeria hat der Kandidat der
Regierungspartei die Präsidentenwahl
gewonnen der 70-Jährige Bolat tinoboo
ließ mit 36% der abgegebenen Stimmen die
Mitbewerber der Opposition hinter sich
die Wahlbeteiligung war sehr gering die
Nobu gilt als einer der reichsten
Politiker des Landes er wurde mehrfach
der Korruption beschuldigt die
Opposition will das Ergebnis anfechten
zurück nach Deutschland seit einem Jahr
gibt es eine neue gesetzliche Regelung
zur Organspende verbunden mit der
Hoffnung dass damit die Zahl der Organ
Organspenden steigt doch die Bilanz ist
ernüchternd
2021 wurden noch
2905 Organe gespendet 2022 waren es nur
noch
2662 ein Minus von
8,4%. dramatisch für die fast 8.500
Menschen die aktuell auf ein Organ
warten Torge Boden
Ralf Westerberg ist 58 Jahre alt sein
Herz ist schwer geschädigt Organspende
war für ihn nie ein Thema er konnte sich
nicht vorstellen dass ihm nach seinem
Tod ein Organ entnommen wird seit dem 28
Januar wartet er nun selbst auf ein Herz
ohne das neue Organ könnte er sterben
entweder kommt oder es kommt nicht was
ich manchmal sehe wenn der Hubschrauber
kommt oh ist da was für mich dabei oder
so in diesem Sinne noch immer ist die
Zahl der Organspende in Deutschland viel
zu niedrig gemessen an dem Bedarf eine
neue gesetzliche Regelung sollte die
Spendenbereitschaft erhöhen doch nach
einem Jahr ist die Bilanz ernüchternd
ehrlich gesagt es hat sich leider gar
nichts getan alles was in dem Gesetz
versprochen wurde ist letztendlich nicht
wirksam umgesetzt worden und was wir
gesehen haben ist dass die Spende Zahlen
im Jahr 2022 noch mal deutlich
zurückgegangen sind derzeit gilt in
Deutschland die sogenannte
Entscheidungslösung wer ein Organ nach
seinem Tod spenden möchte dokumentiert
diese Bereitschaft z.B auf einem
Organspendeausweis experten fordern
allerdings die Einführung der
Widerspruchslösung das heißt jeder ist
potentiell Organspender wer das nicht
möchte muss dem aktiv widersprechen wir
müssen erstmal dafür sorgen dass
wirklich jeder in unserer Bevölkerung
seine Entscheidung trifft das wäre das
verpflichten de und dafür müssen wir
auch den Menschen die Ängste nehmen die
sie haben vor diesem Thema weil es ist
ein Thema was wir nicht ansprechen jetzt
da er selbst betroffen ist und andere
Patienten kennengelernt hat die auf ein
Spenderorgan warten hat Ralf Westerberg
seine Meinung zu dem Thema geändert
noch und wir kommen zum Sport Nordische
Ski-WM in Planitzer und da haben die
Deutschen Kombinierer ja geglindest
Norbert und ihre vier Medaillen die
glänzen silbern Eric Frenzel Vinzenz
Geiger johannes-ritzek und Julian Schmid
müssen sich nach starker Teamleistung
nur Titelverteidiger Norwegen geschlagen
geht geschlagen geben im Tal der Chancen
die deutschen Kombinierer nach dem
Gewinn der Silbermedaille außer Atem
aber glücklich bis heute war ich glaube
das war unglaubliche Werbung von unserem
Sport und auch das finde ich das ja
besser schreiben können nach dem
Springen von der Großschanze geht das
deutsche Quartett als Dritter in das
Verfolgungsrennen über die 4 x 5 km 23
Sekunden Rückstand hinter Norwegen die
stadtläufer Erik Frenzel
zwischenzeitlich aufholt in der
Schlussrunde einen Kopf von Kopf Rennen
zwischen Jahren Magnus rüber und Julian
Schmied Riva setzt sich auf den letzten
Metern ab und sichert Norwegen den
WM-Titel der deutsche Protest wegen
Behinderung in dieser Szene abgewiesen
und skispringerin Katharina Althaus hat
in Obers in Planitzer nach drei Titeln
noch einmal Bronze gewonnen oder gerade
eben vor wenigen Sekunden beim Wettkampf
von der Großschanze musste sie sich nur
der Norwegerin Maren lindby und der
Kanadierin Alexandra lotted geschlagen
geben und hier sehen wir gleich noch das
Ergebnis wenn sie es denn ganz genau
wissen wollen da geht der Balken hoch
und es hat gewonnen die ganz junge
Kanadierin Alexandra lautet so viel Zeit
muss sein oder toller Erfolg für
martinus der Snowboard Crosser aus
Landshut gewinnt seine erste WM-Medaille
Silber bei den Titel kämpfen in Georgien
nur wenige Zentimeter fehlen Martins zu
WM Gold im Snowboard Cross der
Österreicher Jakob Duschek links lässt
sich ins Ziel fallen triumphiert so in
letzter Sekunde Foto finde ich doch auch
um Silber muss der 29-Jährige deutsche
zunächst bangen die Jury überprüft nur
als riskantes Überholmanöver auf der
Piste hier Minuten lang dann Grund zur
Freude die erste deutsche WM-Medaille im
snowboard- seit 22 Jahren
nach Leipzig Wolfsburg und Freiburg
haben gestern Abend auch die
Fußballspielerinnen vom FC Bayern
München das Halbfinale im DFB-Pokal
erreicht durch den 2:0 Erfolg in
Hoffenheim die Frauen des FC Bayern
lassen gegen Hoffenheim die Muskeln
spielen doch bis die Münchnerinnen ihre
volle Kraft entfalten dauert es die
eingewechselte Maximiliane Rall trifft
in der 68 minute gegen ihren exclub zum
1:0 keine 10 Minuten später Sorg Clara
Bühl mit dem 2:0 für die Entscheidung
wie schon im Vorjahr ziehen die Bayern
ins Pokal Halbfinale ein die Paarungen
hierfür werden am kommenden Sonntag
ausgelost
Zusammenfassung dafür Viertelfinalspiele
mit 17 Toren finden Sie in der ZDF heute
App und auf zdf.de
interessante Zahlen für Sie und zwar die
Lottozahlen von heute die Gewinnzahlen 8
14 21 23 28 47 Superzahl ist die 9
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
Trockenheit ist gleich beim Wetter ein
Thema mehr dazu von Essence
hat um 21:45 Uhr das heute journal für
Sie auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter Trockenheit bleibt
weiterhin ein Thema das sehen wir hier
auf unserer regensummenkarte also der
Regen der dazu kommt wird eingefärbt in
blau wir sehen es ja einmal über die
Mittelmeer mit dem Tief was hier noch
mal durchaus bis zu 80 Liter auf den
Quadratmeter bringt ja über Deutschland
wird zum Wochenende auch etwas Regen und
schneefallen aber das nur ein bis zehn
Liter auf den Quadratmeter das ist sehr
wenig Richtung Frankreich sogar noch
weniger da bleibt es größtenteils
trocken so wie die kommende Nacht im
Norden bildet sich Nebel und auch nach
Süden hin ist Nebel dabei dazwischen
klartes auf die Temperaturen gehen
zurück auf -9° nach Osten hin und zwei
Grad an der Nordsee häufig ist es aber
frostig in der kommenden Nacht morgen
dann nach Norden hin einige Lücken in
der Nebel Decke und auch im Süden kann
sich der Nebel hier und da auflösen
dazwischen gibt's viel Sonnenschein weil
er höchsten Temperaturen von bis zu 13
Grad im Südosten und viel Grad unter dem
Nebel nach Norden in die nächsten Tage
zunächst einmal trocken Freitag drei bis
zehn Grad und danach kommt eben nur
etwas Regen dazu ein schöner Abend